[Music]
storytelling is so important for The
Human Experience
storytelling is a way to live hundreds
and thousands of lives in our lifetime
what I think is Meaningful about what we
do is I can tell you a story that
acknowledges you as a human being a
little bit and you take my world view
with you when you walk out we both get
something out of that in a beautiful way
[Applause]
what I think is really powerful about
long-form storytelling is that you can
really dig deeper and excavate and
unfold things that enrich the whole
story
but there's always the fear that you'll
never get to finish it never get to tell
the end of the story I think that's one
of the things that scared me the most
about going into long-form television
here we go and background and action
it's five hours of material every year
that's two and a half movies it takes me
two years to make one film and cut
excellent I'm so grateful that we had
this opportunity and that we got to
finish the story beautiful beautiful
when we started it we knew the premise
and we knew the two story lines but we
didn't really know where it was going to
go and then by the end of that first
season it started to become clearer do
you know who you welcomed into your home
when the pandemic Hiatus does it was a
real moment that was kind of beautiful
for me to sit down and go okay these are
all the different ideas that we have how
many seasons is that how many episodes
is that that was how it kind of came to
be a Four Season show you're getting
more clarity thank you
my name is Leanne Grayson and I come
from Wisconsin
one of the fun ideas for the show was
telling the origin story of Leanne
it can be interpreted in two ways is
this the story of a fallen angel
embodied now in this young girl as she
Embraces this does she become this dark
entity that could really change the
balance of everything
or is this just a girl that has these
delusions and maybe there's a grounded
explanation why would she put her own
baby in your crib
both explanations are plausible that's a
fun story that we wanted to tell
one of the hopes when I hired an
autography was that we were watching
this young girl grow into a woman over
the course of the show and then when we
get to the final season she would be a
formidable presence
I'm scary
[Applause]
what about now
I love that architecture for her what
about now
ultimately what Drew her to this house
is Dorothy she's just in awe of Dorothy
her need for Dorothy to accept her and
love her is Primal it's a mother figure
that she never had
at first it was longing and doing the
childlike things but then getting more
physical
she's so tired of feeling bad and
feeling wrong and feeling like she isn't
good enough
which is all the Dynamics from her real
mom she started to feel it again with
this family
is the fear in their eyes
she likes this feeling she starts to get
to the premise of I need to get
everything out of this house except for
me and Dorothy and this child
I'm never gonna let you back in this
house if eventually Dorothy will come to
see that this is a good thing
that's their fantasy she's gonna do
everything possible to make that happen
just let me take my child and leave
Jericho has always been the embodiment
of love and fragility and vulnerability
that represents all of our hopes and
fears when we have a kid and whether
we're gonna fail or succeed in
protecting them and the helplessness
that we all feel that's so scary
[Music]
whenever we see Jericho as he's moving
through the developmental stages like
his birthday and he's learning to eat
each of these things this is the
treasure that's being given this family
every time they hold him it feels like
it's worth it whatever the cost is
[Music]
servant is about a woman who's forgotten
that she was responsible for her child's
death and the ticking clock about when
she's going to remember
[Music]
why I did this show I I wanted to get to
that episode
her story was so important I wanted to
direct or dissent into madness and I
wanted to direct the moment she woke up
we're all fighting not to have that
painful moment but the irony is that's
exactly the moment we should all be
running to it's a freak accident the
thing that we're scared to say
for fear that I don't know what's gonna
happen on the other side that's very
much Human Nature
I always try to put myself in the
mindset of the characters and say would
I do this
there is no higher Stakes than losing
your child having the person that you
love disappear in front of your eyes
I would probably do anything to get back
what I had lost
Sean has made a Faustian bargain
and realizes that there's no way out of
this you've already made your choice
so be an adult and deal with the
consequences
it's coming at a cost and the cost
he doesn't get to talk about what
happened to them and the loss you should
have been there Julian she called you
but we're not ready to talk about that
are we and we'll never be ready because
you can't handle real life one
inconvenience that you fall off the
wagon Julian is an addict and keeps on
doing forms of addiction whether it's
drugs or materialism he'll do anything
to escape the feeling of guilt and
Trauma that has associated with the
events that happen to this family
there's a pretty dark moment where Sean
and Julian come to the realization that
this girl has to leave this house
we're gonna stop being polite we may
have to cross the line here
hello Leanne it's shocking to all of
them they're questioning themselves wow
when we're fighting for our family we
are willing to hurt someone else
that's what's scary about having a
darker presence near you you start to
take on all of their value systems
they're like see you do anything too to
get what you want
for what we did to you
it is primarily these four actors
constantly interacting for these 40
episodes it is a play essentially
they were game for what I was asking
them to do which is hey we're going to
push the artistic mediums we're going to
shoot these things in unusual ways
sometimes it's not going to work but
we're going to keep pushing it and they
were so open to risk themselves rather
than play it safe
I think they
've to be risking themselves in that way
for those 40 episodes
[Music]
I'm prepared to do whatever it takes to
get rid of me
the biblical story that we're telling is
being manifested in physical form in the
house
the house has always been a reflection
of the family as the house is
deteriorating it's almost like you're in
your own Nightmare and you start to
sense that this is not sustainable
now this has escalated to the point that
we're on the cusp of something
catastrophic if she wins the city will
fall and that's only the beginning
the last episode is reducing all 40
episodes to the Primal conversation of a
mom who didn't get a chance to mother
and a child who didn't have a mother to
mother her
will they be able to find balance if
they can everything's gonna fall apart
not only what's in the house but the
whole world the world out of balance
so we're only been suffering unless you
choose to end it ultimately Leanne has
to make a very difficult choice to help
this family and the world
the beautiful thing that the domestic
story of shattered family and this
biblical story of this dark entity meet
in this storyline of a mother and a
daughter
[Music]
what was really interesting when I look
back on it because I didn't think of it
as my story only there was a little bit
of distance that I had from it that
allowed me to be very loose with my
storytelling in a way that I've never
been able to do I felt to some extent I
was following the Muse in my head I had
all these amazing writers and directors
to help tell this story I got to work
with an incredible group of storytellers
that I normally wouldn't have gotten a
chance to tell stories with
you will distinctly feel each
filmmaker's hands and why episode 401 it
is really different than the second one
which is really different than the third
episode and they're very different than
my episode but it's all one family of
language and I do think celebrating our
differences in our voices and Artistry
will make servant have deep deep
resonance
it's 40 little films that were directed
by these incredible storytellers I've
got
I think forever will be a magical
experience for me
it is something that we had got to do
with such Purity in such an unusual way
when we got to the last episode and we
said goodbye to the cast and the crew it
was super emotional because we know this
is rare to have this much love and
Artistic integrity and something in the
industry is very very rare
I just wanted to thank you guys for
everything I got to do this in a way
with with people I love at the highest
level and you guys just I can't thank
you enough it'll always be one of my
most cherished memories and I want to
thank my amazing cats
[Applause]
thank you
I went to the set for the very last time
I stood there and looked around I did
take one or two pictures
the set's getting torn down it'll never
exist we'll never tell that story again
I know one day I'm gonna be walking and
just start weeping
because I don't know how it could happen
again to have that magic that bonded Us
All
My Hope Is that servant will be watched
for years to come I want it to be
meaningful and stick with you
having had this artistically pure
experience that Apple allowed me to have
I'm so grateful
[Music]